my next guest went from the private
sector is the CEO of coca-cola in Mexico
to the public sector as the president of
my eco sounds familiar actually please
welcome former President Vicente Fox
[Applause]
[Music]
you brought me a gift thank you so much
these are boots
made it quite certain I will not be
going back to United States have a seat
please the world thank you so much these
are beautiful and I will wear these
often yeah yes we have so much to talk
about first of all I get the sense that
you have an opinion about the wall not
just from the boot but from some of your
very colorful tweets that you've sent
out your use of language crosses all
barriers straight now what's interesting
let's talk about the history because you
make an interesting point one of your
opinions is throughout history walls
have not worked that is absolutely real
and we all remember with President
Reagan came to Berlin he did mr.
Gorbachev tear off that wall I think I
was there he didn't say that your
history is good president Fox but it's
not perfect
but yes the Berlin Wall famously failed
it doesn't work freedom Fedorov okay
walls don't work and especially when we
the people of United States and Mexico
we are neighbors
we're friends we're partners and more so
we're roommates we are so much together
so many good friendship so many Mexicans
doing a great work loyal to United
estate
and now they want to keep him with us
throw him out yeah yeah that gonna be a
big big loss for United States
I live in Los Angeles and I've said this
before but you cannot walk three feet in
Los Angeles and not be made aware of the
incredible cultural contributions food
art architecture that have been made by
Mexicans and and so it's very silly we
are already together we are already
together and that is not going to change
with campesinos at the ranch and I
remember when they were tears in the
eyes they would go home and say goodbye
we're moving north we're looking for
opportunities we want to make some money
to have a better life for ourselves and
for our family good loyal loving people
yes they work for the Bush family they
work for the Trump family they might not
have documents but they know how to work
they are decent they're honest and they
contribute to the greatness of that
nation so America is great because of
our people
right then talk about why is Trump angry
about Mexico because that rumor that
I've heard they had properties in Mexico
and that maybe there was some difficulty
he tried to build one of his towers in
the Gulf for the Cortes which is in Baja
it's a sanctuary of nature beautiful and
he wanted to build one of these towers
of course he was not allowed to it was
prohibited and he got mad with Mexicans
but maybe has to do also with color
you're quite white we're talking about
wait a minute I I think I blend in quite
nicely in this country yeah I was in a
telenovela man back off I said geez dude
but he doesn't seem to like the brown
color and a nice awful I mean it's we
Mexicans are chiquitos pero Picasso's
maybe so but we're come yeah like a
jalapeno miss around with us senior
Trump you're going to find it today Rex
Tillerson Secretary of State he's
visiting Mexico do you think he's going
to be proposing peace is he bringing all
the branch in your opinion today they
were playing around again with the wall
and Mexicans paying for the wall and
that they come with that instruction
from Trump it is right to convince us to
pay for the world peace mr. Trump we're
not paying for that I just say one thing
president Fox I appreciate that you keep
talking to Trump but I think
I think he switched channels very early
is we very much wanted you to come on
the show and give us your perspective
our mission here has been to bring
positivity and optimism and humanize the
situation but I was very honored that
you took the time to advise to the share
who could if he wants to negotiate we
have to go for the whole enchilada not
just one piece not just rating and I
just security we he has to learn that we
are his best friends and corner
[Applause]
you know what I love about
you know what I really love about the
president's box is that you use great
visual aids
[Applause]
you